>> KELENNA: PROBABLY TAKE THE
TIME TO GET SOMETHING GOOD HERE,
2-FOR-1, DONE BY 2. AND GOOD
LOOKS ARE PARAMOUNT FOR THEM.
>> BOB: DON'T WANT A FOUL HERE.
AND HE BATS IT AWAY, AND THEN
GRABBED FROM BEHIND CAREFUL
NOW.>> KELENNA: BE CAREFUL,
DON'T DO THAT.>> BOB: DANTE
DIVINCENZO.
>> BOB: KUMINGA BLOCKED THE
SHOT AND THEN HE GOT THE
REBOUND, HE FOUND HIM VERY
ROUGHLY.
>> KELENNA: KEEP YOUR COOL, LET
CLARKSON GET FRUSTRATED, HE
BLOCKS THAT ONE AND MATCHES IT.
>> BOB: WHEN THEY GO, LOOK AT
THIS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LAND A PUNCH
OR EVEN DO ANYTHING LIKE THAT,
TECHNICAL ON CLARKSON AT A
MINIMUM.
>> BOB: A FLAGRANT FOUL.
THIS REVIEW IS GOING TO BE
REALLY INTERESTING.
>> KELENNA: THE SQUARES UP.
>> BOB: IF YOU WHACK A GUY IN
THE HEAD OR NECK AREA AS HE
DOES RIGHT THERE, THAT COULD BE
A FLAGRANT ONE, AND AFTER THIS,
YOU GET TO THE BOXING FIGHT
MODE, THAT'S NOT A GOOD THING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> KELENNA: THAT'S A PERFECT
REACTION.
>> BOB: 25 YEARS IN THE LEAGUE,
HE HAS BEEN A LONG TIME FINALS
OFFICIAL.
MARC DAVIS 174 PLAYOFF GAMES IN
18 NBA FINALS GAMES.
U.S. NAVAL ACADEMY GRAD, THE
LETTER OF THE LAW.
>> KELENNA: SHOWED A LOT OF
RESTRAINT.
YOU DON'T WANT DEFINES AND
SUSPENSIONS, BUT THAT FOUL
RIGHT THERE I'M TELLING YOU,
THE ONE ANGLE WE HAVE, HE
WHACKS HIM IN THE SIDE OF THE
HEAD AND NECK, I'VE SEEN
PLAYERS CALLED FOR A LOT LESS
THAN THAT.>> KELENNA: THAT HEAD
AND NECK AREA, UP AROUND THERE,
AS WELL.
>> BOB: HE SAYING THAT WILL BE
A FLAGRANT.
HE WAS FRUSTRATED AND GOT THE
SHOT BLOCKED.
YOU COULD HAVE A LOOSE BALL
FOUL ON CLARKSON,  YOU COULD
HAVE A FREE -- FLAGRANT, AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WILL CESAY
TECHNICAL FOR GETTING INTO THE
SUGAR RAY LEONARD.
>> KELENNA: THE NBA DOESN'T
LIKE THAT KIND OF ACTION.
AND HE JUST THOUGHT IT WAS
FUNNY.
HE WASN'T GOING TO ENTERTAIN.
>> BOB: GOT CLARKSON UPSET, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WAS ABOUT,
KUMINGA STARTS LAUGHING.
>> KELENNA: I WOULD DO THE SAME
THING.
>> BOB: REGARDLESS, I 2 POINT
LEAD, AND THIS SHOULD TILT IN
THE WARRIORS FAVOR.>> KELENNA:
IT SHOULD.
KUMINGA DID A GREAT JOB, MOVED
HIS FEET, JORDAN CLARKSON
THROUGH EVERYTHING HE COULD AT
HIM, GOT THE BALL, JORDAN
CLARKSON WAS JUST FRUSTRATED.
WHATEVER HAPPENS HE SHOULD GET
PENALIZED MORE THAN JONATHAN
KUMINGA.>> BOB: HERE'S THE
THING, UNNECESSARY CONTACT IS
THE FRUIT FLAGRANT ONE, BUT
UNNECESSARY AND EXCESSIVE, IS
FLAGRANT 2, YOU COULD HAVE THAT
AND OFFSETTING T.
>> REFEREE: A FLAGRANT FOUL 2,
JORDAN CLARKSON, UNNECESSARY
AND EXCESSIVE CONTACT ABOVE THE
SHOULDER, KUMINGA AND BEASLEY
HAVE BEEN ASSESSED TECHNICAL
FOULS, GOLDEN STATE WILL SHOOT
TWO FREE THROWS.
>> BOB: EXPLAINED IT NICELY.
UNNECESSARY EXCESSIVE FLAGRANT
2 REJECTION.
TWO FREE THROWS PLUS THE BALL
AND BEASLEY AND KUMINGA
OFFSETTING T'S AND NO FREE
THROWS ARE SHOT.
>> KELENNA: THAT SEEMS RIGHT.